blutiger kampf um die ukraine er geht
weiter wir sehen hier die bilder aus der
nacht wir sehen die zweitgrößte stadt
der ukraine haake und sie sehen es
selbst am horizont immer wieder gehen
die lichter der
bombeneinschlag ist deutlich zu sehen
240 zivile opfer hat dieser krieg
inzwischen kostet mindestens 10 64 tote
sind darunter das sind tatsächlich die
traurigen offiziellen angaben aus der
ukraine nach der dritten kriegs nacht in
folge und hier sehen wir jetzt auch die
hauptstadt kiew auch hier hat es in der
nacht wieder anschläge gegeben
hier sehen wir filmchen die von
instagram und twitter und erreicht haben
wir wollen ein bisschen rein hören sie
höhere nämlich auch die stimmen der
verzweifelten menschen dort in den
häusern die natürlich angst um ihr leben
haben
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja das sind die dramatischen bilder die
uns jetzt aus der nacht erreicht haben
wie gesagt das sind tatsächlich
inzwischen mindestens 240 zivilopfer
dieser blutige krieg von wladimir putin
gekostet hat wir wollen schauen zu
unseren reportern die natürlich live
weiterhin für uns unterwegs sind in der
ukraine und auch in den grenzgebieten
paul ronzheimer ist für uns weiterhin in
kiew paul wie hast du diese blutige
nacht in kiew erlebt
die nacht-u-bahn vergleich zur gestrigen
nach tatsächlich ruhiger wir sind
zweimal in den bunker geflüchtet wir
haben die ganze nacht bei den
blitzschutz an einem geheimen ort
verbracht haben mit ihnen darüber
gesprochen wie die lage einzuschätzen
ist offenbar ist es so dass sich die
russische armee du hast die bilder am
anfang gezeigt heute war gestern nacht
vor allem auch aktiv konzentriert hat
eine million statt einer großen
großstadt im osten eine entscheidende
strategische stadt für russland dort das
bedeutet aber nicht dass kiew in
irgendeiner weise verschont würde auch
hier hat es explosionen gegeben wir
waren zweimal unten in einem bunker
mussten uns dort versteckten zusammen
mit den beiden brüdern vitali und
wladimir klitschko und weiteren und
gleichzeitig die große sorge dass hier
schwerste grad waffen horten aus
russland weiter in richtung ukraine in
richtung kiew gebracht werden und es
gibt und das höre ich auch aus
geheimdienstquellen die große sorge dass
viel schwereres gerät und auch munition
beziehungsweise waffen benutzt werden
könnten die sehr viel ungenau sind denn
die waffen die zielgenau sind kosten
russland noch mehr geld und man kommt in
der in der schlacht sozusagen in kiew
weniger schnell voran als man sich das
erhofft hat paul du hast gestern ein
wirklich dramatisches interview mit den
beiden klitschko-brüdern geführt dieses
interview musste ja tatsächlich dann
abgebrochen werden bombenalarm und hast
du heute noch mal gelegenheit gehabt mit
den beiden zu sprechen wie geht es ihnen
die beiden halt ne sache stand sie sind
eng miteinander verbunden diese beiden
brüder die die ganze welt kennt aus
ihrer box zeit aber mittlerweile eben
auch aus ihrer politischen zeit aus
derzeit 2000 breitbild bin einmal da an
wo vitali klitschko dir zu einer
gallionsfigur geworden ist dann
bürgermeister geworden von kiew aber man
merkt ihnen natürlich auch die
emotionale belastung an was das mit
ihnen macht mit ihrem land wenn ich die
frage wie es ihnen persönlich geht dann
weisen sie überhaupt ihnen sagen es geht
ja ums land es geht um die leute wir
wollen nicht so viel über uns sprechen
sondern wir wollen dass die welt uns
allen ukrainern hill wo wir wollen uns
gemeinsam malen dieses aktuelle
interview anschauen dass du heute mit
den beiden geführt hast
und wollen uns hier nachdem wir gestern
in den bunker mussten die wir heute
drauf bestanden
wir
schlagen italien platz 49
gedacht war
ich mag zwar begrenzt sind
gesorgt
aber schon gesagt die ganze nacht der
praktiken
den berichten
der regisseur
bei den kumpeln geboten haben
diese gibt was kann
deswegen jetzt ist
ich hatte gestern gefragt was
norddeutschlands und was man zu sehen
was dabei nicht gepasst ich habe auch
kein video
erzählt nicht in deutschland
irgendwie
die grünen verfügen
auf jede art und weise an bord stoppen
hier
muss man als kosten
das wirtschaften
bis 13 wie in jedem anderen berg ist
unglaublich wichtig diese revision
aufhalten sondern mittelstand
was bedeutet dass deutschland in italy
als erstmals brachen sich bahn sprechers
oder angekündigt dass ihre unterstützung
ist eine rede im bundestag des
bundeskanzlers oder
schönsten arien
wochenlang monatelang lang ja auch
unterstützung bevor
das ist wichtig
und
für sie sind die gemüse garten
rheine geht nicht das ist hier das
ringen die ganze demokratische welt
das ist eine gewisse regeln wird eine
sehr wichtig
freundliche frau
wir hatten geplant durch ich
meine chance warten und
wandte sich an den helm ist auch wichtig
aber
nicht wagen
das glücklichste
doch ganz gut
und da werden sie noch nie gesehen
ein mädchen
gegen diesen krieg riskieren
vergessen war
wollen sie wieder zu machen
die knochen die zeigen was es seien eher
die gruppe den fersen
überhaupt haben sie hier sind
für sie
und so etwas passiert
gesperrt
die anderen
komplett friedlich gestartet
und wollte mich sehr wichtig bestehen
das ist mein blick nicht nur wie hier
greift das ist beim picknicken die
ganzen jahre zu hören wir mussten
schwangerschaft danke
wladimir du kennst oder shorts hamburg
bei der bürgermeister dann bezahlt
erhält heute den bundestag versagen auf
sanktionen gegen weißrussland
diese vergessen ist der politischen
leistungsloch und
jede
tennenbronn verbessern
wir liegen beim schwitzen ganz markt
geliefert irgendwie stück besser
über
die funktion
wahrscheinlich jede unterstützung bereit
wie schon gesagt das ist genau mein
kampf diese treten loosen land pläne so
viele krisen in europa
geht es für euch jetzt am tag
wie muss man sich das vorstellen wie wir
jetzt arbeite ich noch was
in deutschland
beim verladen gibt aber auch natürlich
die persönlichen farben sie haben
die beteiligung
hier sind
[Musik]
weil er nutzen werden wir unsere
sportvereine augen jetzt wir stehen seit
einer woche über gestik ist zerbrochen
die die
exporte wie heute kommt her zu kommen
deswegen gebrauchen relation produkt
beachten
wir werden sie haben noch nie
wer noch fragen jungs alles anhören die
schüler wurden für einen erwachsenen der
debatte schon das brenzlig
paul ein sehr beeindruckendes interview
was du da geführt hast mit den beiden
klitschko-brüdern putin führe einen
krieg gegen ganz europa haben die beiden
gesagt und hat sich deutschland ja nun
entschlossen tatsächlich doch noch
waffen zu liefern
glaubst du dass dieser schritt zu spät
kommt
der schritt kommt in jedem fall so zu
spät das ist putin abschrecken könnte
das war ja immer die strategie der
ukraine oder das was hier noch und
monatelang eigentlich schon seit jahren
diskutiert worden ist nämlich dass man
waffen braucht damit putin weiß dass der
preis immer größer wird von daher kann
man sagen der krieg wird dadurch nicht
beendet das jetzt waffen kommen aber
möglicherweise auch jetzt noch bedeutet
ist dass putin sieht die opferzahlen auf
der russischen seite werden immer größer
und das ist der druck der möglicherweise
zum einlenken führen kann allerdings
gebe ich zu bedenken das gilt nur für
menschen die noch einigermaßen rational
denken als präsident wird man das von
einem muss man es sagen kriegsverbrecher
überhaupt sagen kann aber viele beete
neben darüber dass wladimir putin in
seiner völlig eigenen welt ist dass er
in einem bunker ist zusammen mit seinen
militärs mit deinen fsb leuten und auch
niemanden mehr hört was dort passiert
und wenn das der fall sein sollte also
wenn diese experten recht haben dann
bringt es wahrscheinlich keine
veränderung dass es weitere abwehrwaffen
geht aber es ist unsere verdammte
pflicht da gehe ich diese ukraine die
angegriffen wird die anders als putins
lügen ist behaupten eben niemanden
angegriffen hat nicht russland
angegriffen hat hier kein
völkermord vollzieht wie wladimir putin
das in seinen lügen sagt das wird dieser
nation helfen müssen